You gotta be kidding me you're gonna risk
the entire mission for a mental defective
dressed as a court jester this coming from
a guy that wears a toilet seat on his head
we don't leave one of our own behind hopefully
harley's still alive no funny business colonel
these are dangerous people team two is clear
to go fire uh three two what are you guys doing
what you we're here to save you you were gonna
save me it was a really good plan too well i
can go back inside and you can still do it that's
patronizing i'm so sorry harley quinn bloodsport
you know the deal successfully complete the
mission you get 10 years off your sentence
you fail to follow my orders in any way and i
detonate the explosive device in the base of your
so this is the famous suicide squad
any questions
Hand! yes that is your hand very good
we're all gonna die i hope so oh for sake here's
the deal we fail the mission you die we find out
any information you give us is false you die if
we find out you have personalized license plates
you die what no if you cough without
covering your mouth harley although
that isn't an open invitation for you
to cough without covering your mouth
what's the plan how the hell much less enough
you're the leader you're supposed to be decisive
and i've decided that you should eat a big bag of
dicks but this whole beach was completely covered
in dicks and somebody said i'd eat every dick
until the beach was clean for liberty i would say
no problem why would someone put penises all over
the beans well that's why mad men do what they do
this is suicide well that's kind of our thing
don't you worry i'm gonna get you out of your
life i'm going to get you out of here alive
oh my god we've got to freaking kaiju up in this
everyone loves the rain, it's like angels are splooging all over us
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
suicide squad trailer video dc just dropped
a brand new redband trailer confirming that the
movie will be rated r it's coming this august to
hbo max so i'll explain what's going on with the
plot and where it fits in with the justice league
timeline especially because we just got done
watching the snyder cut i'll also explain how
this fits with the timeline of the first suicide
squad movie because some of the characters like
rick flagg and captain boomerang amanda waller
harley quinn are all coming back from that first
film so it isn't replacing or rebooting the first
film the first film still exists in the continuity
they probably have a funny way of referencing it
during the events of this film and they finally
confirmed who the real villain of the film is
going to be it's going to be giant freaking starro
confirming my big theory from the last big trailer
video way back at dc fandom they released the
footage with a bunch of behind the scenes and you
could actually see actors on the set with sorrows
covering some of their faces so i was like okay
starro is probably figuring into the plot somehow
i love the way they reference it within the
context of the movie too like the suicide squad
says look at that giant freaking kaiju probably
the other coolest detail that you may not have
noticed or some of you may have figured this
out but king shark obviously hilarious during
the trailer it'll be fun to see him during the
actual movie but you may have detected that he's
being voiced by sylvester stallone steve agee is
doing the motion capture for him he's playing the
physical king shark when he's running around on
set it's just sylvester stallone doing the voice
of king shark when they announced that taika
watiti was going to be doing a voice during the
film or playing a character my assumption was that
he was going to be king shark and they would just
do a kiwi shark but james gunn said that tycha
is playing somebody else but he wouldn't say
who so now my theory is that the taika is going
to be the voice of starro because what will be
funnier than a kiwi sounding like a korg sounding
giant starfish from outer space that mind controls
everyone probably one of the other biggest easter
eggs at least metaphorically in the trailer
is john ostrander's big cameo scene he's actually
the person who's putting the bombs in each of
their heads if you're not a big comic book reader
he was the person who created the suicide squad in
the comics but i'll explain who the rest of the
characters are if you're not totally sure what's
going on because they have some really obscure
characters in here but it's just like guardians
of the galaxy james gunn is doing the exact same
thing getting you to care about the sea and d-list
characters that you never thought that you would
before they opened the trailer with a rescue
mission to get harley quinn she's apparently been
captured by one of the other villains during the
film there are multiple villains but starro just
happens to be the biggest villain literally and
metaphorically the big joke though that when they
go to rescue her she's already saved herself like
oh sorry guys i could just run back inside
you could try and save me again don't worry
the opening scene here also gives you a really
good idea for what the group dynamic is what all
the relationships are like like they all kind of
hate each other they don't really trust each other
but they are a team and rick flagg wants to save
harley quinn because she is a member of the team
for those of you wondering idris elba is playing
bloodsport he is a comic book character the reason
why he got thrown in bell rev prison is because
his character shot superman henry cavill superman
with a kryptonite bullet so just to explain
the timeline on that like when did that happen
this movie takes place after the
events of the justice league movie
so here's where we get to the timeline and we get
into a little bit of multiverse territory with the
ending of the snyder cut because there are
a couple alternate endings during that film
right now what warner brothers is considering the
canonical ending of the justice league film is
this moment here where they're all getting ready
to board batman ship to go back then you have the
series of endings and you end with henry cavill
superman opening his jacket and flying off into
the sky and that's the end of the movie so they
don't really consider the epilogue the nightmare
scene or the martian manhunter scene to be canon
so at some point after that henry cavill superman
gets shot by bloodsport using a kryptonite bullet
and even though he doesn't get killed he gets sent
to prison after they capture him this movie does
take place after the events of the first suicide
squad film i don't know how long after the first
suicide squad film they'll probably explain when
we get closer to it coming out but rick flagg
obviously still alive captain boomerang is back in
harley quinn from that first team we have the same
amanda waller who's back playing the character but
this time the team's mission takes them to corto
maltese so that's where most of this movie takes
place but it sounds like something really shady
has gone down and starro is involved but there's
also this big coup involved with this foreign army
so it's just one wtf moment out of the frying pan
into the fire situation like you go from bad
to worse to even worse through the film they
do a little bit of a roll call at the beginning
but you know who most of these characters are
like john cena is playing peacemaker the way he
describes him and he's like the douchiest version
of captain america you've ever met like captain
america if he acted more like the punisher and
they're doing a peacemaker hbo series that they're
filming right now james gunn is doing it himself
it's basically built to be a spin-off of this new
suicide squad film so we'll get the suicide squad
film in august then in january next year they're
going to drop the peacemaker show on hbo max
it'll be eight episodes it'll be like the big
budget dc series like the batman hbo series
that matt reeves was hyping up james gunn wouldn't
say when it takes place but i'm assuming it takes
place after the events of the suicide squad film
but it'll also cover his origin story and it'll
involve a lot of characters from the suicide squad
movie as well crossing over onto the tv series
we'll probably get a trailer for that when
they actually release the suicide squad film
they use the rest of this opening scene save
to introduce the rest of the team as well
like you have michael rooker playing savant alice
braga is playing a character called soul sarai
from the comics pete davison is playing blackguard
sean gunn is playing weasel in another rocket-like
performance he also does the motion capture for
rocket on guardians of the galaxy nathan fillion
is playing a character called tdk which isn't
a name from the comics but the name tdk might
stand for the detachable kid which could be just
another way of saying that he might be a version
of arm's fall off man detachable arms fall off his
powers are basically exactly what they sound like
obviously you've seen king shark i've talked about
sylvester stallone doing the voice is basically
just like he is in the comics hello i'm king shark
i'm a shark i was so happy when they confirmed my
theory about peter capaldi playing a version of
the thinker much more comic book accurate version
of the thinker they did him on the flash season
4 i think it was i wasn't super happy with the
way they did his special effects towards the end
of that series but i'm sure this big budget peter
capaldi version will just be absolutely ridiculous
in the best possible way they're also doing mon
gal from the comics she's a version of mongol's
daughter so obviously they're going very cosmic
with the movie as well because the villain is a
very cosmic villain starro i don't know if they're
going to have any warworld easter eggs during
this or not harley quinn's costume seems like
it's inspired by the alternate red version of her
costume from the comics and as far as i can tell
this movie takes place after the events of the
birds of prey movie movies in the dceu tend to
move in a linear fashion unless it's like a wonder
woman situation where it takes place in the past
so at some point after the events of the birds of
the prey film she just got thrown back in bellerev
prison david dasmartian you might recognize from
ant-man and the wasp or as abracadabra from the
flash tv show he was actually just in last week's
episode of the flash he is a comic book character
he's playing polka dot man just as ridiculous
as he sounds flulaborg is playing javelin he's
a character from the booster gold comics most of
you might remember him from youtube it's weird
to see a youtuber show up in a movie this big
in a role that big i'm going to take a stab in
the dark and say people will probably enjoy this
harley quinn movie a little bit better than they
enjoyed the birds of prey movie they do another
montage introducing you to some of the newer
weirder characters like michael rooker's character
i always loved seeing him show up in james gunn's
films they did a lot of these types of scenes
during the first film but i feel like it got so
muddled and they had like two different intros for
all the characters during that i have a lot more
faith in james gunn's ability as a screenwriter
because he's both a really good proven writer
he knows his comics he's a long time comic book
stan and he's got a proven track record as a solid
director of big films like this all these jokes
feel like very classic james gunn like listening
to john cena go on about how he would love teed
all the dicks on the beach if somebody ordered him
to do it that's a pure james gun joke right there
he's probably one of the few people that could get
john cena to deliver a line like that like wait
a minute you want me to say what in this movie
the whole thing with nathan fillion in the pib too
james gunn explained that pibb is the only soda
that he likes to drink so i have a feeling that
that's how it wound up being in the actual movie
it sounds like based on the narrative in the
trailer the way they're presenting these scenes
that peter capaldi's thinker has something to
do with them infiltrating courtois maltese in
whatever the actual mission is what it is that
they're actually going for because starro sounds
like he's as big a surprise for them in the moment
as he is for us the audience finding out that he's
in the actual movie the whole thing with them
hyping up the tagline don't get too attached is
the idea that it's called the suicide squad for
a reason they are extremely expendable so don't
get too attached because some of them might wind
up dying james gunn didn't say how many but i'm
sure some of them will wind up coming back for
sequels that the film does well enough i don't
think that's going to be very hard to do i feel
like anything would be an improvement from the
first film but apparently dc liked what he did so
much they gave him that peacemaker hbo tv series
i think with the exception of a few odd flashbacks
most of the film is supposed to take place between
belle rev and corto maltese if you're not familiar
with corto maltese that's also a big location
in dc comics it showed up in the batman comics
originally but it's an island like mad rapport
in the marvel comics it's just a place where
a lot of really shady people go to do business
big black market area overall it looks ridiculous
in the best possible way i can't wait to see more
footage and they just let james gunn crank all the
dials up to 11. but if you spotted any big easter
eggs during this that i didn't mention during the
video just write them below in the comments i did
videos for the other footage that they released
a while ago at dc fandom so i'll link that down
in the description below and some of the other dc
fandom trailers like the batman trailer there's
been a bunch of dc footage don't forget we're also
getting the batman movie next year around this
time well you wait for everything everyone click
here for my brand new justice league snyder cut
ending and end credit scene video and click here
for my brand new falcon and winter soldier episode
2 video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!